how are you chase claypool of the
pittsburgh steelers what's going on
am i live am i laughing you are live
you're on with rich eisen sir how are
you you're on the rich eisenstein oh
good you're on the right i'm sorry it's
treatment and it
ran over a little bit no it's all good
uh you're on the mercedes-benz vans
hotline as a matter of fact i don't know
if you feel that energy but at any rate
thanks for calling in greatly appreciate
it have you ever seen die hard you ever
seen that movie chase uh yeah is that a
bruce willis that's a bruce willis movie
how old are you again by the way just i
am 23. okay all right so you're the
movie's older than you um so let me ask
you this question do you think die hard
is a christmas movie chase claypool yes
or no oh
i've seen this debate somewhere uh no i
don't think it's christmas oh
chase come on bro chase come on bro we
have you sure no no no be quiet i'm the
host of this show
and chase clayfool is one of my favorite
players in the nfl
i haven't been fantasy it's not a
christmas movie right what would you say
is a christmas movie then chase i would
just i would say like um the little
snowman movie um
and then
write
elf that's a christmas movie elf it's a
christmas movie it's about an elf right
when i think of christmas i think of uh
happy times i don't think of people
dying that's right you don't think well
he saves the day
but he's a terrorist chris no there's no
terrorist you rid the world of terror oh
my god chase you're a smart young man
you keep balling out the way that you do
i really appreciate that for sure
well done um so let's get to the
football aspect of this thing um
did something click this past week that
uh hadn't in the first four weeks
do you think offensively for your team
um i don't know if it was something that
just click i just think um everyone's
starting to get better and um understand
scheme more and executing better so i
think the running game opened a lot of
things up offensively
yeah so how different is the scheme this
year what can you walk me through that a
fan might uh
relate to on that front the difference
um
our schemes not too different i think it
um it's more different for alignments i
can't really speak
i'm too much on that but uh
i think the linemen they improved
against green bay the run defense or the
run offense has improved and then it
carried over to denver so i think the
line
um scheme has just they've been
executing better so the line scheme has
changed up the the manner in which the
the blocking scheme
is brought to bear offensively is
is pretty much the uh a difference from
last year to this year is what you're
seeing yes
okay and so that's gonna take some time
as as you might imagine so what do you
think um clicked for your running back
and naji harris what do you what do you
see in him
i think um you know i think it's just
like every rookie in the in the league
you know the longer you play the better
you get the easier
you know things are the game slows down
you see things more clear so
you know the more we run these plays the
more he has trust on the way to go and i
think that's what he's been doing lately
and how about you how have things been
different for you year one year two you
sound like one of those grizzled
veterans right there chase but you're
talking about being in this league long
enough so uh what what about you that's
uh a little bit different or you're
you're better at this time around
yeah i think just like seeing coverages
um
even if they're disguised knowing
who's about to cover you knowing how
they're about to cover you
um just like little nuances of you know
matchups i think that's what's been
improved the most for my game okay and
how does that affect your ability to
you know feel confident
going into a game yeah well i mean if
you you know if you know what to expect
then uh it takes you know
that takes all the stress out of the
game and you can just go play freely so
the preparation and stuff is a big part
of just going out there and playing free
chase claypool of the pittsburgh
steelers here on the rich eisen show
fresh off of his first triple digit
receiving yard performance of the year
um let's talk about 7-eleven um how's
big ben doing there's a lot of talk
about whether um he should have returned
this year i'm wondering what he hears
and what you guys talk about
yeah and he's done i mean like he played
really good oh man i even think he
played
um pretty well against green bay um you
know it's it's tough sometimes not gonna
have a good game every game just like
i'm not gonna have a good game every
game um you know people are pretty quick
to jump to conclusions about
his health or um whether or not he
should return but
um
i i think it was you know i was super
happy that he came back and i still am
so
so what is your relationship with him
how much do you do you talk ball with
him can you walk me through like a
regular day that you have with your
future hall of fame quarterback chase
claypool
yeah i mean he'll you always make a
point to a
pull us aside um
in the locker room and talk to us about
anything that's gonna happen in practice
anything that just got like installed
you'll be like
uh this is what you need to expect
and then so that happens basically on a
daily basis uh i'm right next to this
doctor so sometimes we'll talk about
little things like what tv shows they're
watching and stuff like that but
um it's pretty it's mostly football and
yeah what tv show is he watching what tv
do you show you do you share a tv show
that you guys are watching um i'm trying
to i think we're trying to get them on
money heist
that show okay oh got the free plug
right there okay
[Music]
and squid game oh gotta get them off
jeez i gotta tell you uh chase my wife
and i took in the first episode of squid
game and we're like what the hell was
that
you like it but you like that it's a
great show yeah
what do you like about it
that's like calling that movie
a kids movie because they play kids
games just like die hard
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes chase claypool it is just because
they're playing children's games like
red light green light does not mean it's
a kids movie it's just about kids games
yes
yes chase you're just giving me
ammunition kind of like the squid game
but yeah i just couldn't handle it so so
ben's not watching the squid game right
that's right um i gotta i gotta i gotta
follow up on that i think uh i think he
might have but i think he was also
finished in the show i can't remember
which show uh
okay
yeah i i just don't i just i don't know
man i just it was i i don't know if i'm
gonna go in for episode does it get
better in episode two or or or what is
it just more the same walk me through it
chase no it does it's like a twist
already in episode two and then uh you
know there's all these little like
easter eggs or like hints about
um you know about the show that's like
hidden in the show okay that's super
cool once you keep watching you pick up
on some things so
um definitely gets better okay
is tomlin watching the squid game do you
talk to your coach about that he he is
we got him to watch squid game and he
loved it
wow okay what do you mean you got him
you just walk into his office and you're
like you know i know you're watching
film under your grinding tape i know
that stuff but coach you got to watch
the squid game you literally say that to
mike thomas so you're saying no we're in
the stretch line and we're all talking
about it and then he's like what are you
guys talking about you're in like squid
game you gotta watch it he's like ah
i don't know if i can watch it
and he came back the next day and said
he he watched it and he liked it so i'm
sure he put his kids to bed before he
watched that that that we we can't have
kids around for that one we cannot i
mean you just right i mean yeah you
don't agree with that okay very good all
right um and in all seriousness before i
let you go how is juju smith schuster
how's your how's your your comrade who's
now done for the year how's he uh he's
good his uh spirits are high i was at
his
his foundation event yesterday um so
super cool that he still put put that on
even with his injury and he went and
spoke to all the all the guests and
stuff like that so
um
you know he's doing really well and he's
gonna continue to be a leader for us i
love that so he he he honored his
commitment despite having surgery sunday
he had his he had his event monday in
the community he still he still did it
that happened yeah he
invited us out um
invited my mom to come too so that was
cool and we we all enjoyed that so your
folks live in pittsburgh is that what's
going on too no my mom's just here for
the we're here for the game i'll just
hear from you
all right chase all right chase i
appreciate it um okay uh i'm i'll give
squid game another run i'll give it
another
whirl and i'll just think about you and
that you told tomlin to do it and the
rest of the steelers are doing it and so
i guess you're one you're you you're 1-0
since uh mike tomlin started watching
the squid game is that basically what
you're saying right now
yeah this is true yeah okay green light
right
yeah karina
all right take care chase thanks for the
call appreciate it you'll be well i
appreciate that chase clay pull
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here